wir sind eine autostunde nördlich von
new york city und wir sind hier genau in
jenem vögel wo die impfungen ebene
stattfinden und wir haben hier einen
arzt aus der intensivstation dr
er wird jetzt praktisch demonstrieren
weil hier wie so eine impfung abläuft
wir gehen hier jetzt in diesen in diesem
raum hinein aber er hat selbst keine
bedenken hier sich die impfung geben zu
lassen und jetzt werden wir sehen wie
dass wir das hier abläuft
jetzt wird das protokoll eben
durchgegangen die die mitarbeiterin
fahrt jetzt irgendwelche vorerkrankungen
und so weiter das ist auch sehr wichtig
und jetzt sieht man erzielt man jetzt
beginnt das ganze natürlich der abend
wird der oberarm linker oberarm
desinfiziert und jetzt jetzt die impfung
ganz normal dass wer sagt das ist wie
ein moskito stich haben wir mit einem
stich in wirklichkeit also das ganze ist
jetzt wer gesehen hat in wenigen
sekunden abgelaufen
der ganze vorgang hat gedauert
vielleicht 20 sekunden und jetzt was
erwartet wird bei dieser impfung sind
ähnliche symptome wie auch bei einer
grippeimpfung
er erwartet jetzt keine großen
komplikationen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren